good morning Hank it's Tuesday I greatly
enjoyed your video about sports that
ought to be included in the Olympics but
there was one big problem with it which
is that the Olympics only occur once
every four years and I for one am not
willing to wait until 2020 to watch some
live televised hesse the head centric
version of ping pong headus muggle
Quidditch the settlers of catan World
Championships human backflip racing
demolition derby soccer featuring an
excavator serving as goalie all these
amazing sports share one commonality
Hank their brilliance goes largely
untelevised I mean Hank if I can't watch
one man wriggling beneath two other men
while all three men are simultaneously
jumping rope why do I even have cable I
mean here is an incomplete list of the
24 hour sports networks currently
available in my area and yet somehow
I've never been able to watch live
professional double mini trampolining
and that's just a travesty so in the
2004 movie dodge ball the dodgeball
world championships are broadcast on a
fictional sports network called ESPN 8
the Ocho in real life of course the
dodgeball world championships are not
televised at all and there is no ESPN 8
although for the record ESPN does own 8
cable networks but there is a subreddit
called to OCHA where you can find
highlights of lesser-known sports from
remote-controlled truck racing to tug of
ors a sport that despite being born from
a pun is incredibly entertaining let me
submit that the Ocho would be a wildly
popular cable network slash streaming
service it could be your TV home for
everything from well-established niche
sports like the ones in the Olympics -
you know competitive log-rolling which
requires amazing balance or foot
billiards which yes exists and yes is
awesome I just want to highlight three
more sports that I think would be
awesome viewing on the Ojo first are
leaping which is a very popular sport in
the dutch province of Friesland are
leaping is essentially an exaggerated
pole vault over a moat and it is
terrifying and beautiful and I love it
why is there no television program
called far leaping weekly then there's
cup stacking and exciting sports it's
also very fast-paced like well I've been
talking about it you watch someone set
the world record we should be talking
about the stars of cup stacking every
night on SportsCenter
and lastly Ultimate Frisbee it's the
best part of football plus the best
parts of basketball and it happens to be
the sport that I played in high school
to get out of my physical
education requirement but I'm not going
to lie mostly one ultimate frisbee to
receive more attention because dogs are
pretty good at it which makes it the
sport most likely to inspire the new Air
Bud sequel our dark and broken world so
desperately needs Hank with our super
abundance of sports media you'd think
there would be room for more than four
or five sports but bear isn't at least
not in the US and that bothers me
because sports with a cult following are
loved deeply even when they aren't loved
broadly like anything with a cult
following the Internet has been pretty
good at building homes for communities
like that from primitive technology
YouTube channels to bands that sing
about Harry Potter but for reasons I
don't really understand that hasn't
happened with sports yet if it ever does
by the way I suspect it will be known
not as ESPN 8 the Ocho but instead as
YouTube sports I can't help but hope
that maybe someday I'll find my true
calling as the color commentator at the
far weeping World Championships Hank
I'll see you on Friday